and how was it transitioning from Tokyo
to LA I know you said you had visited
here on there if they're visiting is so
different from the living here and
actually I had a very hard time like
first six months because I didn't know
anything about this culture and then
also the system for example like I've
never had of the credit card history so
they're settling down is the most
difficult I had their several friends
through my job because I came here a lot
for business so they helped me to
understand what is it but they're um
maybe I really enjoy the life in Tokyo
to you know there to have I have a
little friend in Tokyo but here you know
it's so difficult and then on my age
maybe it's harder to make new friends
and then also culture things we make
friends through the business all the
time but here kind of separate right a
professional friend and enter the out
private friend so maybe I didn't know
how to make friends there privately
because we don't have any wall in Japan
so professional friend turns out their
private friend as well and then did you
know it's so mix Wow so yeah that was my
hardest things still live here it seems
like a lot of women make friends to
their children and then they are friends
with their moms I think I thought ya
said they have to you know be at home
like a weekend and then right yeah
you